nah
[Music]
n
nah
[Music]
n
come
nah
[Music]
n
what's going on
guys what's going
on how's you guys afternoon
man you know let's have a little
conversation before we start you know we
haven't started yet let's have a little
conversation oh there we go front and
center front and center what's going on
guys I know we've been taking a little
break you know uh sh shout out to the
people over there at uh Star Trek Fleet
Man Star Trek fleet commander
they they have sponsored this stream so
your boy came up off the bench let going
here to play what's so interesting as I
was I was looking into it a little bit
you know what's funny is like this is a
type of game that uh I love I love these
strategy form of games they're fun to me
you know it kind of reminds me of like a
spaceship form of like XC XCOM so I'm
really excited to you know really try
this and you know s see what it's about
man we we going to see we going to see
you know obviously I told them I got to
give my honest opinion if I like it or
not and they they agree they they want
honest feedback and you know I always
respect to people that do that man you
know that they want your honest feedback
on whether or not you know they need to
what they need to improve what they
don't need to improve and I like when
companies actually let you know
influencers be influencers cuz one of
the reason re we don't do a whole lot of
these things is because I I feel like
you
know you feel like you might get
blacklisted just being honest with it
but you can easily give constructive
criticism in these streets and a lot of
Studios you know and a lot of companies
in general they they definitely want
that honest feedback just some people do
it completely
disrespectfully and uh we're going we're
going to give Star Trek fleet commander
a fair Shake man we're going to play
this for about about two hours I did
talk to
King we looking at maybe doing a
community day too how you guys feel
about that a community day we looking to
play that as well because I figured hey
we already
streaming we might as enjoy ourselves in
the in the process man that's what we
doing here we going to really give it
our
all I appreciate you guys coming through
man I appreciate it let me share this to
Twitter we're going to get we're going
we're going to get
going uh almost done
guys
all right there we go let me put this in
here and we should be
good all right there we
go all right let's start this man let's
start this let me get let me shrink us
back to where we need to
be there we go all right let's start
this first thing I want to point out is
what I noticed about because I played a
little bit of the tutorial because I
wanted to get a little bit of a feeling
of the game before I played this like
this is I saw some stuff like I've never
been I've never been the biggest Star
Trek fan I'm more of a Star Wars fan but
I like that this game is connected to
Star Trek and they're actually giving me
a little bit of little bit of lore it's
always nice on that you know there is a
lot of aspects to Star Trek that's I
find intriguing but I've never really
jumped straight into you know I always
like these type of space battle things
you know uh where you have to fight over
certain you know territories because
that that's the that's the vibe I'm
getting from the game right now so I'm
kind of interesting to you know see
exactly how this game expands on that
and I I looked up a bunch of videos to
see you know what I was getting myself
into and a lot of people really you know
enjoy this game it's on it's on PC it's
on mobile I'm pretty sure it's on Mac 2
uh you know it's I like that they give
you a lot of places where you can play
this
game so let's let's go over here and
attack this
thing all right we scanning it so they
do give you like a little a little
aspect you know
172 over uh you know I think it was like
147 we won obviously cuz we ain't going
to lose you not bad it would be if we
started losing on a sponsored stream we
can't do that we can't do
that now I do wish they had voice
commands in this game because sometimes
I get a little bit more immersed when I
hear voices speaking I I'm kind of
curious on the aspect of putting voices
in games I'm kind of curious on the as
it must be expensive because I feel like
a like I feel like there's a huge amount
of people that would be willing
to to do the voice thing just to get
into the industry for a fraction of the
cost so I'm kind of curious on that
thank you for the
unexpected
compliment
geredi I don't I'm butchering that I
assume you're referring to the
Enterprise now I do know the Enterprise
is something from Star Trek I don't like
it's like the one that comes down and up
I do know that I'm not I'm not
entirely you know um uneducated in Star
Trek I don't even know what the
Enterprise is it's like one of those big
things that people love and I I am
familiar to that to some degree man I am
familiar to that to some degree so let
let's let's uh let's pop through here
and see more
man you sure were data that's that's an
interesting name I wonder if that's like
actually in Star
Trek what's up bone
slave
the one that comes down and up I look
look I'm telling you it's like it's like
a round shape here and then it
like okay you right you're right cello I
don't know what I'm talking about I got
the visualization in my head I'm
thinking about it in my head just having
a hard time explaining to it like in
words you guys know how I am with words
I'm horrible with words
you guys know you guys know me by now
how long have I been doing this how long
and you guys still get
surprised all right let
me one
second yeah all right
yeah see here's the thing here's the
thing
I don't know Star Trek to that degree I
will inform the captain standing by data
out that's what I like about this
because it gets me intrigued about the
universe itself and I ain't going to lie
like I really I'm vibing with the way
the map is set up like I assume these
are ships that I could fight because
that when I was looking through the
tutorial it kind of divided like a map
like we fighting for territory so I'm
kind of
curious how that is you guys get what
I'm saying I'm kind of curious how the
interaction is uh with the dividing Maps
because it kind of reminds me of like
the Star Wars Battlefront you know
galactic Conquest I'm sure you guys
remember that uh so I'm curious where
that
goes Hey listen there's another reason
I'm out here it's not just for some Star
Charts I guess Star Charts is like the
maps of the Galaxy I don't know can you
give me water please gu say I don't know
I got something that Fleet can't know
it's a prototype artifact intelligent
Constructor I found well then I'm hoping
to leave you with meet
Maya Maya thank
you oh she she's AI you know CG's really
pushing AI these days man CG's really
pushing AI Cog wants this world he wants
the AI to rule everything man he wants
Cortana to to take over everything right
on time Maya it looks like you've been
able to integrate your systems with
station Commander it is and impeditive
that the constructors doesn't fall
through in the wrong hands don't you
love how everyone feels like they're
gonna build something for the for the
for the good of mankind and it ends up
always in the wrong
hands isn't that like
the blueprint to every AI taken over
over the world movie or Universe like
Terminator things like that you know
they built something for the good of
mankind and the news flash is not the
good of
mankind keep an eye on her from me
she'll help you out with the station
while I'm
gone uh Gerald the Enterprise is
retrieving another nearby team away
which is for us to take you to the Ronde
Point Let's Move
all right
so we got to go to the Ronde point which
is a minute
away that's a that's a grip away if this
was Starfield I'd have to refuel like
three times I'd have to go to like three
different planets to go this
Direction look at that man can I see my
ship can I look how nice that ship looks
that's my ship that's no one else's ship
that's my
ship back says depends on the pricing of
the game for voice overs cheaper games
usually use text ver uh
voices uh versus voice at overs I can't
imagine it's cheap if you have someone
like Patrick Stewart read lines but
here's the thing I don't think you have
to have Patrick Stewart read lines
I now obviously I don't know how this
stuff goes but I do feel like they
amateur people I see people on Tik Tok
doing like lines and stuff off anime all
the time hire one of them people you
know it' probably be cheaper than hiring
Patrick Stewart I don't even know who
Patrick Stewart is is he like someone
from actual Star Trek it would been cool
if they would have got actual Star Trek
people too that would have been pretty
cool oh Patrick Stewart is he's he's the
commander dude okay okay acknowledgement
Commander thank you for looking over at
Maria she see I that's where I feel you
that's where I feel you I I feel
like I feel like that would cost a lot
of money that to get Patrick Stewart I
feel you on that so if you understand I
have a lot of advice for you but Duty
Call so listen up attack the Hostile
ships yeah Professor X uh you see flying
around the star system for loot they
appear in red keep improving your ships
and the station it's good to be prepared
and last but not
least space is Big we saw a huge map man
uh there are plenty of people looking
for your help accept missions from as
many planets as you can find the rewards
will be worth it now I guess it's time
to depart I'm leaving the station and uh
May uh Maya or Maya I don't know how you
guys think I should pronounce that Maya
or
Maya I see the title screen
are you saying that there's another dude
with a beard in the title screen and
that's
me what what are you guys talking about
me hold up I think it got the wrong
thing
all right there we go can you guys see
that see you guys have me tripping over
here all right you guys should be able
to see it
now have me tripping over
here all right we good can everyone
see what do you guys
mean hold look at it now look at it now
hold I think I fixed
it all
right on my screen it says it's fine all
right
on my screen it says it's
fine see man this is this is this is the
stuff I'll be saying
man see man this is this is this is the
man why won't the screen actually pop
up it's very
frustrating yeah I hear you man I hear
you all right what about
now I think that might have fixed
it all right I think we good about now
are we good that might have fixed
it yeah yes I know what happened um I
was panicking pushing stuff all right so
we resetting the clock 15 minutes guys
we're resetting the clock 15 minutes
that that was that was my B that was my
mistake all right what's funny is like
they have like a a pre- launcher you
know how like when you load steam
there'll be a a launcher for like uh you
know what's good uh Divinity original
sin bers Gate 3 how there's another
launcher after you click it uh they had
one of those and for some reason uh OBS
was like we going to stream that hey
babe what's going
on
uh I I cannot believe that happened
normally I get that stuff good but we
resetting the clock all right 15 minutes
so we we doing this for a little bit man
for a little bit all right so we got the
there there's an AI going on right now
I'm a program respond to emergency
situations and inform you about the
weapon fires on short range centuries uh
perhaps we should
investigate look at D daa over there
who's
Denna all what she what we doing here
there is a nonsense vessel that matches
the configuration of a known nence
warlord who operates in the area I will
I will open a channel to him all right
so we speaking to some one in this area
let's
see look how crazy he
looks Commander they are attempting to
hijack the light hauler the independent
crew aboard will be powerless to stop
them if we do not
interfere uh this is a mobile game and
it's on PC uh so you got a lot of
options you can play you know a lot of
options you could play
it
got these these These are look crazy
looking ships got a lot of uniqueness to
them hold up what's fi training oh okay
they're just showing me this like
different I guess it's like a battle
pass kind of
thing all right so we we we did the
mistake and identify this game is called
Star Trek fleet commander now look you
guys will see the steam Labs bot coming
in here doing my job for me all right if
you guys want to try this this is a good
game to play you know when you sitting
around the house you know sometimes my
girl like doesn't let me play games I'm
gonna be real with you yeah I'm talking
about you sometimes she she she give me
that side eye that side look I got to
get off but you know what I can do I can
play star track fleet commander that's
what I can can do get the tablet get the
phone see I can't play it on the PC cuz
she don't like that you know it got got
plenty of places where I could play this
there's a large warship propotion
configuration is unknown uh to me they
have sent a request communicate with
you uh what we have here you are not
Starfleet what a uh little ship you have
and I am a subc commander the Roman star
Navy it's crazy this dude got red eyes
is that what all these people look like
in Star
Trek you guys about to forgive me I
don't know Star Trek like
that is that what all these people look
like in Star Trek they look crazy like
this a bounty hunter wanted uh wanted
for high cribes against Empires hiding
somewhere in the system maybe you can
bait him out before we trust you with
that I would like you to know if you can
handle yourself go find another uh go
find and defeat another regular
Destroyer I guess that's the ship name
even you should be capable of that man I
don't like the way he just said that
even you should be capable of that
that's
disrespectful how does he know me why
would you ask someone to go do something
and then disrespect them in the same
breath you know kind of makes me want to
to shoot
him you never be disrespect respectful
for no
reason I resent
that all right so where does he want me
to
go all right so we got to we got to find
another one of these can I can I attack
any of them oh it looks like I can
attack any of them should we hit a level
one or a level two I feel like we can do
a level one
chat I don't feel like we should attack
the smallest person in the
room I feel like we can hit a level
two that's just my
opinion level no
come Chio Walker my dude we can destroy
we can we can win a level
two we can live a level two don't tell
me we can't live a level two you you you
have to have faith in
me you have to have faith in me no
there's tons of different alien races
from different planets in the Star Trek
universe that all look different look my
girl right there with it man she got
faith in me she knows that we do what we
put our mind to it I so you are
so okay okay okay let's let's try it
let's level two actually is these the
highest levels that's in this facility
right now hold is there a level two
right here yeah let's do it let's do it
we got
this I hope they both don't attack
[Applause]
me look I got some type of I see I told
you I told you we had a level
two guys be second doubting
me if you assist with his capture and
Empire will allow you to remain in this
sector so I guess these
people what is
this all these
people oh they like yo we ain't letting
you attack him they like we that's a
little bit too strong for your
life oh that that's
funny I am conducting a sensy sweep of
the planet for the Target Target located
I will plot a course to intercept their
ship okay where's their
ship oh
the we got
[Applause]
[Music]
it I like how like it's it's pretty like
like resourceful you can actually see
like the the shields got a lot of
attention to detail you have my
gratitude resourcers Independence like
like yourself can make quite the career
with the right contracts you know
perhaps you may serve us yet
again all right let's see here
intervene we're running out of time for
every repair we make another Rapture
occurs save
us okay so we don't got to repair
anything right now let's just go over
here let's just wing it
do the small
favor I'm actually really vibing with
like the the concept of this game we
have to come to assist you I have badly
wounded crew and my ship is tearing
itself
apart all right so how will you
help the crew we can either recruit
bravely treat the
wounded or we can recruit and repair the
ship now I personally feel
like we got to repair the ship even if
the people are wounded they can go home
and get W it treated what's the point of
repairing the ship I mean treating the
wounded we just leave them here imagine
someone shows up and your ship is
unflyable and you pull up like I'm I'm
I'mma heal everybody I'mma Pat you up
I'mma Pat you up and then we just we out
we out we going to leave you here you
know you know you're going to be fully
treated of your wounds but then you're
going to die of starvation CU we ain't
going to help you get out then again I
guess if we treat the
wounded maybe we'll treat someone that
can fix the
ship I don't know I don't
know I feel like it's a it's a it's a
bumpy road I feel like it's a bumpy road
so we going to repair the ship if if
you're able to contain the hall breach
that will buy us enough time to make the
repairs okay so there are people there
that can make the
repair what is all
this oh it's like little Hub
stations oh you can eventually attack
these
things all right so they do another
small favor mission complete we got we
got some data and some officer XP we
could always use more XP it don't matter
what game the old fangi proverb that
scared me expand or die is wise advice
in a Galaxy At War as a fleet commander
you must upgrade your station to extend
your
capabilities expand your crew by
recruiting new
officers construct powerful new ships
and explore the Galaxy see that's what
it looks like defeat dangerous enemies
testing your Commander's prowess the
final frontier is
your yours
Commander make it
so I respect that repair the related
first and manager ship and choose the
officer and assign them on board
okay let's go
back we got to repair the
ship assign a new recruit to your your
ship I don't really
know what I like about we got to sign
someone
manage assign
officers let's put him here uh cry is
the benefit of a captain gains from The
Bridge officers diverse SU
experiments provide the most benefit to
the C uh Captain it's preferable to put
an officer in each class on the
bridge all right so pretty much you you
you need people to help run a ship
essentially all right so I assume you
can change it depending on what you need
like to make the ship it's kind of like
a little bit of some of the same
mechanics that's in uh Starfield so
that's interesting
all right so you can have multiple
ships as you recruit more officer to
assign them to your ship to strengthen
your
Fleet okay so we we already did that uh
as officers get more experience they can
level up and enhance their abilities
choose an officer and increase their
level all right so
which we'll do this dude because he
looks cool isn't isn't this dude in the
actual I've seen this
dude and like TV and like Tik Tok and
stuff like that isn't this dude in the
actual Universe of Star Trek we're gonna
level him up though I feel like this
dude's the actual
individual what's his
name Chio he is data so he's he's
actually in the UN
Universe we're going to level this chick
up
too all right we good on
that remember to level up officers
regular to maximize your Fleet
strength I detect two n approaching one
of them is hauling is haing us we're
trying to make uh make an ally room you
should have thought about that before
you attack uh my Champion bro is here
with his Fleet to destroy
you oh I feel like they they want
beef how many are
there are we attacking
them oh there's a there's a TV show
too I I did watch the movies I enjoyed
the movies I didn't watch the TV show
but I did watch the
movies we going to win this
[Applause]
fight stand no
chance told you you are no match for my
flag
shot oh so I got to fight another one
okay
Demi was the [__] counselor for the Star
Trek next Generation are those good are
those good should should I give them a
chance man I don't think I seen the last
Star Trek
movie Bardock [__] man he's on
me you may have defeated me but garma
was uh would not easily fall we will
meet again Independence come dude I just
blew up your ship in space there should
be no rendevu for
you like did you like blink yourself out
out at the last minute like someone
explain that to
me I know there's people in this chat
that watch Star Trek how is this man
alive I blew up his ship in
space he should be suffocating or
whatever you do when you I mean I mean
theoretically he burn up in the fire is
there a reason that he's able to walk
around kind of curious on that
maybe lorewise they got a reason in that
case like when what are you ever going
to to to
win Commander the re the theia I'm
butchering the name of that I know I am
is soon to face enemies that are too
strong to take down if you want to s a k
strong enemy you need to upgrade your
ship first we need to get ready the ship
ready return to the station once you get
back repair the ship and we can upgrade
it
I feel you on that kill but here's
here's my thing that's a
copell oh so that's how they do it so
they they got like a whole a whole
system okay once the ship is repaired we
could upgrade it uh increase the
strength once the chip uh upgrading the
ship you might add new comp uh
components to it so they got like a
little little system where you know
upgrading ships and stuff that's
interesting when all the components are
fitted you can tear up the ship once the
completed this will make the rellia
significantly stronger significantly
stronger I expect to be able to fight
more people with that
one all right so we got a damag ship so
we got to repair
it
and
then we got to upgrade the ship look at
that nice little ship man that's the
ship I have in my
dreams that's it right there look at
that you guys know you want that
ship the ship is
legit
uh
all right level
up all right is that all we got to do I
enhanced my
shield we should be able to take on more
ships
now
I am level
two upgrade your ship to tier
two
upgrade all right so we did the FI
training
tier
up we want it instant we ain't
waiting I watched the original nice
starter [__] but there was a ship near
him what is the starter ships like
random I wonder if uh any of you know
that regular upgrad ship will maximize
the power of your
Fleet tune
up Commander I am receiving a discr call
from a Starfleet science space in a
nearby system we should investigate at
once we
flying we going
fast now I know like their holes and
stuff they don't fill the speed
in
this but it's it's kind of
interesting because I know we won't be
like traveling in space in my lifetime
but hopefully soon thanks for responding
to our distressed car our AWA team
discovered a strange artifact on an
unpopulated Planet but we raided but we
were raided by Nal
Pirates I ain't going to even try it and
now the artifact belongs to me I'll
fetch it for a frying price on the black
market try to stop me and a gruesome
death will be your
reward okay let's see
here let's go get
him it's like it's like I said guys you
see that streamlabs link right there man
you see that click that and let's tell
me what you guys think I'm curious on
that man you know tell me what you guys
think I do enjoy these type of games and
General cuz I I I like I like strategy
games take the artifact unless a piece
of junk by the next time we meet in
inter Looper will be the last days you
draw
breath the enemy is the enemy sheep is
uh fleeing we should R de with the star
Fleet vessel and assess the
damages I do get like very V five like
strategic senses in this
game just did the math quick and I
watched over
600 is it really that serious like is is
the lore behind Star Trek that like
immersive thanks for getting rid of that
nuisance are getting Boulder in their
attacks we received artifact captive my
initial scans indicate that it is some
kind of unidentified technology it cans
a fragment of the message the r return
find a beacons of perish intriguing
you're welcome to keep it and continue
your research we're late for a revew
with inder let us know what you find
out okay
fragments add to your crew by recruiting
skilled officers from across the Galaxy
and accessing them ship assigning them
ships recruit a new officer
now all
right we're recruiting standard room all
right so we
got we got a next gen uh
rer we got a nextg
chiro and we got
um we got nextg la la Forge I think I'm
saying that right La Forge am I saying
that right guys la
Forge oh look at these
chests oh that's
right we got all of
them oh I got the name right for
once oh I just avoid the conversation
who was the best Captain so there's like
a huge argument that who's the best
Captain oh I got a bunch of uh I got a
new player
gift so H how
big how big is that argument
guys because I think there's a a legit
argument you could be you C you could
you could have I
do I don't think it's black and
white let's see what this
is we got a welcome
gift all right
yes you're pronouncing the name
correctly so what is the the the big
argument to what is a good Captain what
a bad Captain is to do do they have like
actual reasons that they feel like one's
better than the other or is it like just
just one of those things where they're
both equally as good just people don't
want to admit who's better who's not as
good
is that what you guys are telling
me kind of curious what you guys mean by
that are you serious is that
bad
wow I mess with
though I analyze the device and receive
from Captain America it's it's an unnown
known ancient
origin some kind of
power upgrade the space operations
building and will allow you to perform
more advanced scans on artifacts
okay we got to upgrade the SK I like
like the the Aesthetics of the game I
think it's uh pretty
gnarly okay we're trying to
upgrade
scans all right so let's upgrade the
scans inducing the battle
simulator battle the most iconic ships
across the Galaxy and
simulations people don't understand how
tame the are you you serious it ain't
that
bad it ain't that
bad I don't believe
you ain't no way it could be that
bad
ain't no
way all right so we did the level
two we got that taken care
of they're very extra with give
rewarding
us I might have to to to try it out man
I might have to try it
out I do I think I might have to try it
out ad do they
face they do it face to face and not
online what do you mean like like
conventions and stuff is that what
you're saying they do it face to
face on kind
of interesting is that like a con is it
like a Comic Con or something or do they
or like Star Trek have its own
convention
Star Trek got its own
convention they've been doing it since
the
70s
oh oh
gosh how you doing
babe I hope you you're having a good day
regular upgrades will allow us to
enhance the station and expand its
capabilities I will continue my research
into the ancient
object collecting these
things all right so we we leveled up a
little
bit independent Peak we know you assist
the uh the Romanians in the capture of
our Ally I will sheath my blade into
your skull unless you perhaps you can
Rectify your mistakes by proving your
Worth to us this is a Trader hiding in a
sector a dis a Dishonored and disgrace
former member of the High Council find
this worthless deliver Justice and your
life might not end this
day both have their own conventions in
well as ComiCon wow that's both have
their own it's it's
real
okay let's see
here search for the kingdom
Trader I miss you too
bab after the stream uh you know we uh
we we plan on trying to play a little
bit of Halo infinite babe if you want
when you get back you can play with
us Commander I have located the target
but they are arming their weapons and
targeting us I advise a proportional
response oh we're just gonna attack this
dude like
straight okay there's no response we we
going in
hot
[Applause]
we always win in these streets so stop
the assault you have bested me I have no
wish to enter stop State okay let's try
this let's try we have I have no wish to
enter
stav car
stav star or star star V car St V car
before my time guys did I get that right
did I I pronounce
that that right I feel like I did but I
probably did you were sent here by
carbon were you not the coward will not
face me himself he has behaved like a
Roman worm lying and scheming to shame
me into the
council St
aore
how St aore how do you this why okay we
got another
choice we got another
choice we can let him go free or we can
bring him to the
brig now I wonder if like things change
depending on what you choose I'm kind of
curious on that if like decisions you
make changes off of if I let him go or I
bring him to the
brig I'm curious on
that I'm feeling we let him
go I feel like that that would be the
correct thing to do to let him
go I feel you on
that I might watch the shows you know
playing this gamees kind of get me a
little bit intrigued to the universe of
the game we're going to let him go
I know my revenge on carbon but I
remember what you have done for me this
day look how close you are to like Earth
like the sun look how close these ships
are to the
sun look at
this I feel like he's right there like
anytime something serious can go
down
you fail to eliminate katak how dare you
return to me with failure said you
worthless Gog I should have known that
it was a mistake to trust a
spineless man these languages are crazy
you will have to work harder to get the
lency from
me oh so ke okay
so all right all right so these people
want me to they they about to smoke is
that what you telling
me these people are about to
smoke they ain't trying to hear none of
that they about to smoke I respect
that I respect that you're GNA come on
here and talk your talk deal with the
consequences that's just
me once we build an academy you receive
more offers that can assign to your
ship what's up
soady what's up so
shady he is my disrespectful Co we will
receive more officers each time we
upgrade the academy we got a level two
Academy
now recruitment
[Music]
drive I will give you one more chance to
prove your worth freelancer this is a
federation Outpost nearby that needs
investigation a sharp knife is nothing
without a sharp eye scan The Outpost for
me determine its defensive capabilities
and return me with your
findings all right so so so so
chat
chat is these the people that I'm
working with now that's about to smoke
or is that another set of people because
I've noticed if you look at the world
and let's look at the
world
oh hold
up no we're not doing
that okay we got allies there
all right so if you look at the
world it's kind of gigantic I'm GNA be
real with you like here's the different
factions like this is a very
expansive expansive game to be honest
with
you I'm with
it
all right so we going over
here
boom we're
warping Killians are a Warrior
Race All right so
they what's a good example so they
like are they like Elites from
Halo maybe
brutes feel like Elites are more of a
Warrior Race than brutes I don't
know I don't know how I feel about
that clling
on
all right so let's see here we got to go
here to
schemes this this is a big game this is
not a small
game greetings friend I see you scanned
our Outpost is there's something you
need yo he knew that we was scanning his
Outpost imagine how like insecure you
would feel if someone just popped up
like yo what you what you
want what you
want I feel mad
insecure of like I don't want nothing
man oh so we
got are you serious there's colleges
that offer courses on like Star Trek as
a whole or just the clean
on all right
so what is your purpose here so we do
got some two choices here we could tell
them that you're spying for the for the
Cleon or we could lie about your
attentions okay me
personally I feel like I feel like
lying's the
way I feel like if I tell these people
yo I'm over here on some on some crazy
stuff I feel me personally if I was this
Commander
dude I'd be calling the
cops okay I'm like we ain't doing that
you know and I've seen in Star Trek that
got like weird beams that keep you from
flying
anywhere I know I got a cool little ship
but I don't think I got a ship to
compete with that stuff now I don't know
if these people have
it you know cuz this dude kind of looks
more human than anything so I personally
feel like humans probably wouldn't have
that technology I don't know how
advanced humans are in star track
either they could be the most deadly
people ever and I don't
know I feel like in the world of Star
Trek the last thing you want to do is
make people mad that you don't
know that's me
though
what do you guys
feel we
ly yeah definitely Cog we ain't trying
to make people mad at me well it's nice
to have a visitor out here anyway
carefully on your way I love how easy
that was he just straight up believed
me no
arguments no fighting just straight up
beli me I feel like it should be harder
than
that right there guys in the Stream
laabs in the chat right now is the link
to the game once again shout out to to
Star Trek fleet commander shout out to
them for for uh setting up this sponsor
ship
stream go try it out man it's a free
downloadable game you you you might like
it because I you know like I showed you
it's pretty expansive world you know
think I might download this on my tablet
it's like I said sometimes sometimes my
girl be hold me
hostage you know I can't get out of bed
you know but I can hold a
tablet I feel I feel like I feel like I
can get away with
that you got play Tye with one
hand you because this hand would be
rounder feel like feel like right there
one hand now Federation has a a
reputation of being good guys some uh
some a lot of trust of races trust them
okay I assume we're charging to go back
to the main menu thing
exit
station we will meet again glory is
yours to be had if you desire it okay we
completed
scheme we ready to upgrade the ship
considering the threats we have fac face
so far it would be prefer to enhance her
capabilities okay so we got to upgrade
the ship
again we got to repair it
first then we got to upgrade
it okay let me see
here
upgrade
upgrade upgrade
upgrade we're tearing
up we're going to do an instant one
man do we need to upgrade again or we
fine okay tier three I like how you can
have multiple
ships never figured you as a team oh all
right all right Bas teacher what do you
mean by that is there something I'm
missing a Tre oh are you saying is that
what you is that what they call the Star
Trek
Community a
tricky is that what they really call the
Star Trek
Community oh that's
crazy I don't know if I would be down to
be called
that I'mma be real with you I I don't
know if I'm okay with
that a track a uh tracky a
tracky Star Trek
tracky I don't know
man you have proved your courage
independent now prove your metal hostil
have uh have been foolish enough to
attack our trade routes
recently prove to me that you are
honorable by slimming their numbers
three ships no less this man's like go
out there and take out some of those
numbers so we can show up
later he's lowkey saying be a
distraction if you get took out you get
took out but be a distraction I don't
know how I feel about this dude I feel
like he does not have my best terms
there all right let's scan
this all right so we we are definitely
we stronger and we're going to get some
rewards from this attack so you know I
think that could work out well for
us
think they want me to take out three of
them which one does he want me to take
out
uh looking for the right one
let's upgrade
that that's
good
locate how do you scan
them upgrade your ship's weapons
increases damage per
round okay I got
you I feel like my ship's strong enough
though that's my
opinion all right locate
we want to upgrade
that all right what else they want us to
do let's upgrade
that
wonderful and then yeah we want to
collect that we need that I need all my
stuff locate
all right we'll upgrade
that we still got to build
this all right so this is like building
ships that is a weird looking
ship
we want to build the the Orin convert or
whatever it's
called this
thing all right so we need a little bit
to do
that all right so let's do a little bit
more research
locate let's go attack this
thing always preferred over 4K Uber
track myself is that another term people
use 4K Uber track
I don't really feel that
either I'm gonna be real with
you we about to go we about to pull up
on this dude this poor dude don't even
know what's about to happen to
him this is your last day Lance
[Applause]
[Music]
Vance oh is he going to get
him got
him all right so let's see
here all right we want to locate another
one we going for the
jugula Warhammer
[Applause]
[Music]
4K
oh we got
him all right let's locate this
one we going for
everyone they got nothing they could
do we pulling
up
[Applause]
you have Sears world no I have the last
battle for you Commander we have two
Targets an Oran criminal responsible for
sabotaging of a cing on warship and the
Federation science vessel relying
tactical information to Starfleet choose
your target this is going to be another
two thing we're attacking
him all right so is it gonna be like a
big bad guy
hold up where is he oh he's in another
galaxy he's over
here
oion you guys love correcting me it's
ridiculous and I don't mind it I'm gonna
be real with you guys I don't mind
it I've never been the greatest at
pronouncing stuff in in
general
so I don't mind people giving
pronunciations at this point it's kind
of been like a a little joke little
jokey
joke you know we uh just a little fun
thing that you guys can uh bring up
man I had enough of these hostile ships
floating around in the junk heaps
causing troubles for my customers
head over there and take out a few ships
of for me and I'll make it worth your
wild I'm trying to run a business here
with the
okay here we go man th this gets wild
with all the races that's in star track
I feel like I'm trying to pronounce
every other word with with these people
I don't even know what this dude looks
like what do you think this Dude Looks
Like Coca-Cola or Pepsi uh I'm a I'm a
cocaa Cola guy myself I don't mind
Pepsi all right all right all right
so this dude says he's got enough
problems well he didn't have to come to
me as in can you a simple Merchant
distress someone has taken my star trap
and
then okay so we got to help him could
you spare oh so he wants $500
I feel like that's a
mistake I feel like $500 is better off
in my pocket probably know how to spend
it
better we're going to
donate thank you Commander thank you I
swear all of this and I think I'm ready
to retire we're going to accept the
mission I command it's you this is
fortunate I'm working with the ship to
deliver extra medical supplies to nearby
col
and it's broken down they've had a
faulty supply of pars still ruined uh
the recent repairs that have been done
to the bulkheads on two if you
could yeah sure a customer at last has
been rough few
weeks does this dude want money from me
too all right so lost
Vestal let's go
there where
this game's like almost a little bit too
big you can like really make a point man
the the these ships are starting to look
different
too we're going for them guys we're
going for
them Genesis or
SNES now I feel
like see I I played more the the
Nintendo platform
but I feel like if if I say s NES Cog
might kick me out of the
podcast I feel like Cog might kick me
out of the podcast if I say s n
yes y'all see WB and paramod are are are
merging where where are you seeing that
from all right so let's see
here they give you a lot of stuff to do
man
legendary and the finest com comedies of
across the
Galaxy a client of mine who purchased
the Elmora Hollow scripture that pricess
work art design I'm sure you've heard of
it it's ready to be picked up in a
nearby system I will regard you for your
discretion generous fee got a lot of
stuff they want me to do art deer let's
go to the art dealer
first
Legend of Zelda
man uh did it just happen like breaking
news just now you the carrier I have a
package transfering to your cargo ship
right away he told me to make sure it
remains sealed don't even think about
opening it or tampering with the casing
even scanning the interial can damage
the pro the projection Matrix oh no that
terryon Bandon his M he to try to steal
the hollow Scot for weeks don't let him
get his hand hands on it we're going to
defeat him we don't we don't mess with
that where is he there he is we got him
actually let's scan him first no we
strong enough let's do
it oh that's what's
up ship
destroy
wait
uhuh did my ship just get
destroyed I feel
away I feel
away
they set me
up these people set me up they were
deliberately trying to blow up my
ship now I feel like I got to go repair
this sucker and go back for round two
and then round
three man I've little in my feelings a
little bit I like that [__] I mean it's
it's being repaired but like like
still I don't know Star
Wars or Star
Trek chat that's that's that's a that's
a key thing right there Star Wars or
Star
Trek I don't
know I don't know I
think I think Star Trek sounds
fun I would say Star
Wars
Star
Wars that's
legit Star Wars what do you guys
think what do you guys think Star Wars
or Star
Trek Star Wars or Star
Trek
all right let's scan
him see I'm stronger than him I bet you
it's cuz my ship was destroyed
let's oh it won't let me attack him
again where is my ship now
though hold
up
hold
up yeah I told you guys we ain't playing
now we going for the
jogu oh where is my
ship let's locate my ship my ship's in
another
world I'm not I'm not feeling that we
going
back we going
back yeah we going
back all right let's go back to to my
ship oh God we are so far
away it's
unreal all right so we we do need to go
back all right we're about to be there
guys never got why people think you have
to pick between Star Wars or Star Trek
or DC or Marvel it's like a game you can
enjoy every platform I feel
you all right here we go here we go we
round two
[Applause]
[Music]
fight oh I'm pleased to see that you
have tampered with the see there we go
guys I got that Revenge it's probably
because my ship was was like severely
damaged when I attacked I think that's
what it was like my ship was like
severely
damaged that's that's my guess of why
that dude because that dude got me he
got me really
good I think that is is is generally
what
happened we're going back to the art
deal though
got to get that
money a powerful Fleet requires an elite
crew promotions with enhancing officers
abilities and uh attributes and
abilities all right
so
deployed okay hold up
let's upgrade
this
operations we can upgrade
that let's upgrade it
again requirements not met we need a
generator this do
that okay what's
this all right so we're good on
that for the record 40K curb Stomps
track or Stars easily in my opinion not
even close but whatever I've actually
always been interested in like checking
that out just seeing like the Star Trek
kind of stuff I mean the 40K stuff uh
they did they are making like a like a
strategy type of game so I'd be very
interested to try that
out right there
guys uh streamlabs posted a couple
minutes ago a link to it's our link to
this game you know definitely go out
there and try it out man try it out I
think you guys would like
it I just want you guys to know what
that link is cuz I know it's never it's
never been in the chat before so people
that come in and out of the stream I
want you guys to know what that will
take you
to I feel like I should have leveled
something up I feel like I miss make a
mistake is my [__] going to blow
up okay we're good we're
good you know what why we at
it I think I should be
fine let's shoot this down too
[Applause]
[Music]
might have
to heal myself after
this okay what are we at to
now okay
so so that's my Shields is the top
one and my health is at the
bottom
[Applause]
[Music]
so we destroy that real
quick I don't know if we could take on a
level
three let's recall
it think it's best to get out of
there let's go
home
Star Trek is the sju and Star Wars is
you chiha it's a good
analogy I would say that's a pretty good
analogy we're going to repair this
free they do give you a really nice like
anything below five minutes we we let
you go sucker straight out the door I
enjoy
that uh let's collect this
promote an
officer
U so that gives your attack plus one uh
I feel like our attack needs to go up
more hers was what
11 all right so the middle guy so far I
think is the dude I'm going to level
up he gives 11 and health though I think
we need more of an attack
thing right
now all right
so he's leveled up correct did we do
that
right promote to the next rank to level
up
recruit oh
promote Ultra
recruit they extra with these names look
let's read these names chat let's read
these names do you want to ultra
recruit do you want a premium
recruit do you want to have a
standard
recruit okay the Federation recruit the
Cleon recruit and the Romanian recruit
makes sense because those are different
factions but I think it's funny how they
do
stuff all right so standard
recruit I think it it was him that I was
looking hold
up
promote officer to Junior we'll get that
here in a
second Rome ulon Rome
ulon I can feel that we're going after
this
dude new ship new
me that's where we're at right now new
ship new
me oh look at that he's just rotating
around that planet I'm literally going
to come on here after he rotates to
start shooting
[Applause]
him look at all these ships here that
could help me or they could have done
this and I didn't have to
leave oh we got to take out another
level
one yeah let's take him
out we got it guys we got
[Applause]
[Music]
it you defeated the Hostile ships
Commander keep it up and you'll make an
aim for yourself in this sector well
thank you thank you I'm trying to make a
name for
myself all right so what is the rest of
the things that they want me to
do so we got to collect
that uh we still got to upgrade that but
I don't want to do that yet promot
officer to Lieutenant Junior
grade oh we got to go back hold
up can't do none of that while my ship's
just
chilling we got a
recall all right let's see
here that was was wondering why there
was no
[Music]
music all right so now we can level
up okay I already leveled them up a
couple
[Music]
times collect more officer shards to so
we got to do a little bit more before we
can level
[Music]
up let's go get
him I'm about to be a straight Menace to
Society to these people over
here I'm about to straight get
him get him shoot him
[Music]
down we've defeated the Hostile ship
Commander keep it up and you'll make a
name for yourself in this
sector defeated another level two we
going for the whole
trifecta
[Music]
let me see here I still have to upgrade
a couple of
these but we're going to just take out
as many ships as we can
see like that's the right thing to
do all right here we
[Applause]
[Music]
go we shooting them down guys we
shooting them down
[Music]
chat The Limited three hoses of level
three or higher
[Music]
we have to go here for level
three I feel like level three might be a
little too much I mean up here says
we're level
[Music]
four got all these things we can
do that's
nice I wonder like how much lore they
have in this
game
compare view the
[Music]
system right so we're looking for level
threes all right where's some level 3es
I saw a level three
earlier
but they kind of took off on me this
looks like this is nothing but level
ones we should
[Music]
probably I would say let's
let's let's
recall probably best to recall right now
because we don't want to be put in a
situation where our health is too
low so let's repair the ship and then
we'll go from
there yeah we're repairing that
ship right there we go now we got to
find some level
[Music]
threes
find some level
[Music]
threes oh this is a bigger play oh there
level six is
here okay so let's find level
threes so here's a level
three so it does look like we are
stronger than them so should we
shouldn't have an issue taking that out
[Music]
all right here we
go all right so not too issue too much
of an issue don't look like they too
much took too much from us either so
we're going to go straight for the the
third one let's let's just finish the
trifecta
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so we good there you defeated the
Hostile chips Commander keep it up and
you'll make an aim for yourself I think
we finished that so let's grab that
let's see what they want us to do
[Music]
next
so we do got to build this
[Music]
eventually we need a level five Shipyard
and we need to unlock the the blueprints
themselves and you get a level five
Shipyard we need an operation Center and
a research and
development
all right so let's do
this let's level that
up start some
research uh let's look
for combat away teams Galaxy what's this
A we don't want that
territory we good raw
Mulan is that that someone in the in the
game research and
development all right let's upgrade
[Music]
again I takes 15
minutes I don't really need that right
now I want to see what it'll take to
make
this
we need a shipyard level
[Music]
five so reach devel level we we still
need a little bit
[Music]
more
so
operations that's level
four we need operations level five so
let's just go ahead and get that
now because we are going to come back to
that and we need an academy level three
to level up again I
believe so let's see what it takes to do
that uh sure why not n we
we we don't need to really rush
anything oh I hit the wrong
one oh okay my my thing's full okay I
can't build no more right now
that's
[Music]
fair it's an enemy race to comes end the
man this this thing is is
deep you guys are
definitely making me feel
very Under Pressure I'm not going to lie
to
you you got you got the the rule on uh
the Rome you
land you got the the the people that
demand
[Music]
[Applause]
death all right we're good there we got
to take out a couple more though we got
to defeat five level twos or higher
hostiles so let's look for some more
level twos here's the level two right
here let's go get him real
[Music]
quick
we stay with
it all right so we are about half half
of our damage right now down here I
don't know if we want to continue on our
Onslaught but we're going to take we're
going to keep going until we get to
about 20% I feel a little bit less
comfortable with it's about
20% um we only need two more we might be
able to take out the the other two I
don't
[Applause]
[Music]
know all right last one guys last one
I'm pretty sure we need one
more yeah we need one
more last
one
[Music]
you defeated the Hostile chips Commander
keep it up and you'll make a name for
yourself in the sector all right so let
me go
ahead get that taken care of now they
want
me can I can I take on level threes
right now you know I I don't feel
comfortable doing that I I feel like I'm
going to lose if I do that let's not get
let's not get greedy let's go back home
let's re
relocate feel like that's the best
course of action right now cuz here my
thing I don't want to blow up the
ship I feel like just repairing is for
the best right
now just when you get the oh God what do
you mean rub their
ears what
you you're almost twice as strong as a
level I it says I'm level four though oh
you talking about the power level okay I
feel you but like taking all multiple at
once was definitely doing a number to my
ships
so so I feel you on that so you got to
be safe then sorry K uh Kio like we we
ain't trying to lose the ship all right
we trying to go to the promise Zone we
ain't not trying to lose the
[Music]
ship all right so now that we're here we
need to find another level
three here's another level three over
here let's go for him take us 15 seconds
to get get to
[Music]
him get him get
him we got full health full
Shields feeling very
confident right
[Music]
now
soon they they
will oh so they call
backup oh
God if they can call backup I I ain't I
ain't trying to deal with that I'm going
to be real with
you I'm not trying to deal with they
backup
[Music]
no level 3es in the immediate area
man yeah I have demolished most of the
level
3es
[Music]
okay we got to go somewhere
else I have a feeling I'm going to
regret going to this this
galaxy I feel like I'm going to get like
absolutely massacred in this
galaxy we're about to find find out
[Music]
though wo this is this been a little fun
time
[Music]
man all right let's see what we got
here we got some level twos
we need threes
though have I really took out all the
threes in the whole
[Music]
galaxy there's no way I took out all the
level 3es in the whole galaxy
[Music]
yet all right so we don't have a warp
drive for that
yeah yeah sure what's not let's let's
let's travel
there kind of curious what's
[Music]
there this game is gigantic
man these are the
territories level 34 23
it's probably like unknown
[Music]
territories let's locate
this oh
God oh God yeah we're going to be
careful here level fives level
fours we could take this
though but you can just read you can
you can add lower deck characters to
your Carew I don't know yet let me um
they have it hasn't came in the
um the the tutorial
yet but I'm sure you can there's no
reason why you shouldn't be able
[Music]
to
[Applause]
[Music]
I
what's up guys what's
[Music]
up
oo all right we good
[Music]
I'm looking at something right
now so we we need
a oh they want us to get fives no still
[Music]
threes if you watch Star Trek Voyer they
talk about how they go through War homes
and it transfer to the system it take
them 100 years to get
wow I even look at my
health I am getting a little low on
health
let's
recall last thing we needed to do is go
through stuff right
[Music]
now let's start building
again oh what's going
on what is that
in a Galaxy At War you need to have
friends commanders who work with you for
greater
rewards because in the silent darkness
of space it's good to know someone has
your
back alliances are crucial for
advancement find your alliance commander
and boldly go even further than you have
[Music]
before
a board
[Music]
Cube board Cube I don't know if I'm
trying to mess with that I'm going to be
real with
you what was the thing I needed was over
here we got to meet level three
Academy all
right oh so we got
to we got to there's one more thing
that's leveling up first
[Music]
okay I need to watch them
again
[Music]
I kind of don't want to go nowhere right
now I'm about to level that
[Music]
up
almost no one no one V one with a Bard
Cube yo I can beat a board Cube level 1
V one don't don't don't test me you
don't know the capabilities of my
ship how dare you not assume my ship
can't handle
[Music]
that all
right
I'm actually really interested
in in the world of Star Trek right
now I'm not I hate that I
do I already have enough issues with my
life than to to get interested in
another thing in my
life I do one Cube can wipe
out one Cube can wipe out all of my
ships
this stupid heart I wish you can get rid
of this
heart cuz I can't see what you're
[Music]
saying 50
ships oh that what was
[Music]
that I kind of want to fight a cube
now okay hold up let's repair the ship
first cuz we still got we get we still
got some little terrorizing that we got
to do all
right do we got any more of these little
boxes that we can
open I don't
know o we got a little bit from the
now keep in mind when you
[Music]
redeem when you R uh when you play the
game you put in uh War speed it will
give you uh it's like a new little
Player thing I think you guys would like
that give you a little bit of little bit
of a u a little bit of a buff going into
stuff Cube stuff regenerates and you
need specialized weapons to take them on
[Music]
all right we got to go back out we got
to go back
out go to the
Galaxy now where was I yeah let's go
back
here I feel like we could do more damage
[Music]
there
self
regenerates okay
okay uh
Walker you need to put in the in the
comment section or the chat whatever you
want to call it what should I watch
tonight my girl's going to hate me but
we watching Star Trek what what's the
first thing and I want like even if it's
not as good as the original if I can
find something that's a little bit more
modern I prefer to watch that cuz it
would be easier to get my girl to watch
it all right view system now what we got
still take on level threes
[Music]
no we still got to get the academy which
we can upgrade that
[Music]
now
all right there we
go all right so I don't think we need to
upgrade this anymore I like this
system all right so let's go back to our
[Music]
ship let's find our ship let's locate
that now we got to find level threes
there's one right
[Music]
there TNG G what is that I'm I'm
unfamiliar what that terminology
is what is
this there's missions
there I ain't trying to go there right
now though we got to find another level
three let's get
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
oh Next Generation I think I've seen
that I don't know the Star Trek
franchise like that but I do think I've
seen Star Trek next Generation I don't
think I've seen the one after that
though I'm I'm a little sure about
[Music]
that we need a new
Academy all right so we need more
[Music]
resources all right so let's go to the
interior the
[Music]
W all right we need a level 14 operator
but we don't got
[Music]
that let's upgrade these get more from
them level six
operator we haven't done that yet we
need level six and a new level six
generator we don't got that either
yet we'll get us
soon okay so I got a reach level 21 to
get some more
goodies okay
we got six right so we can upgrade this
now we need we need 800 we got
800 all right so let's go back to our
ship cuz we keep getting
distracted let's located it over
here we got to find some level
threes what is
this
[Music]
oh it's a Mining
facility I feel like some of these are
going to attack
me I need to be careful with
[Music]
that
all right let's let's try this
again there level three now we're good
on health for right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we need one more one more
level
[Music]
three yeah there he
is
like I said right there guys the
streamlabs uh join it on the fun you
know that that's the link to our uh
associate leak you know if you guys want
to try this game
out I'm actually really enjoying
it I these games always get me man they
always get me can we level up any of
those people yet we got about a little
bit left on
that oh they want hold on do they still
level four people
now oh
God so we're I think we're good if we
attack
them I don't think they're going to like
destroy us
[Music]
[Applause]
yet
[Music]
all right so we're good
there we don't need to do anything with
[Music]
that all right so you think I should
start from the original Star Trek movies
we need to find more level uh level
fours the good thing is there's like
there's a lot like a lot of level
[Music]
fours I don't think I really checked to
see what the damage was oh yeah we about
yeah I'm surprised I live from that yeah
let's go home let's go home
chat oh that
was that was
close I want to fight one of those cubes
so
bad I really do I want to fight one of
those
cubes like really
[Music]
bad this thing up here is almost done we
should be researching I just don't know
what to research yet I guess we can
always research
um level one
great
research ship
[Music]
offens yeah let's always have some kind
of research oh okay right
here all right it's at the let's let's
get the researching done man
[Music]
it I really do feel this is very XCOM
like like now I feel like they they they
need this feels very XCOM like I I Vibe
with it cuz unfortunately they're not
giving me an
XCOM
yet all right hold up we got a
heill Star Trek the Next Genesis is the
second show series and where bog is
introduced okay all right so we got to
get this whole thing down where where
everything's
[Music]
going all right there we go let's build
again now remember you guys always want
to be building stuff at all times don't
waste that
time
all right so that I want to see how
close I am to making this ship
now we need a level five
Shipyard in order to do that we need a
level four research and
[Music]
development there's a character from the
original movies that make cameos in the
Next Generation you can watch the Next
Generation and go back and watch them
depend on the time where where you want
to start okay how far back do I want to
start I'm kind of curious on where I
need to
[Music]
start so where would you guys recommend
me
start I need an unlock I need to do
research
all right so I am doing that research
okay we're
[Music]
good okay where was
I my ship's
repaired we still got some level fours
that we got to
[Music]
fight
what
[Music]
all
right
star Zachary I'm going to watch Star
Trek this this this damn game game got
me I'm scared to get stuck into another
damn show man especially one is as
massive a Star
Trek that Cube got me interesting I'm
not going to
lie we're looking
for level fours there's level four
so
I don't know man they had a big cute
blowing stuff up that apparently can
regenerate itself his name is
Bor gives me very Mass Effect
Vibes need destroy the level
four these things are taking a decent
amount of damage for me every hit now
though the first show is created in the
60s and the second show is created in
the 80s have they remade the first show
cuz if it was created in the 60s I
expect a remake of
[Music]
[Applause]
that we defeated the Hostile ships
Commander until you keep to make a name
for yourself in the sector
okay we did
it level
five oh hold do they want me to fight
level fives yet hold
up no they still want me to fight level
fours okay so we good right
[Music]
now no remake that is very offensive
look man it's like playing games back in
the 90s
sometimes it got to be remade for
current
[Music]
Generations the newest movie go back
where Captain Kirk started okay what
what what movie is
that okay I don't know if we could take
one
more I'm very cautious about taking one
more uh I think it's just best to be on
the safe side
let's
[Music]
recall I think it's best to go back and
double check guys I think it's best go
back and double
check
[Music]
now watch the the newest movies okay
okay see here's the thing like
I I would be
too nervous to watch like the newest
movies I mean the the old stuff cuz I
feel like I might not get into it as
much I don't I want to be fair but you
know sometimes it's hard to watch those
old media content once again guys the
link that just popped in there for the
people that that's joining uh that is
the link to uh the game you know try it
out man it's on phones it's on uh you
know PC it's on everything you know
maybe they should put this on Console I
actually think I would I would pay for
them
this this is Star Trek fleet commander
man you know for for our uh for our
strategy
[Music]
Gamers that popcorn smells
horrible all right we got to go to the
system
[Music]
Galaxy let's go back to
no we just trying to go back here set of
course 43 seconds got to blow up a
couple more level
threes
all right let's no we got to find more
level fours I think we got to find four
more level
fours yeah four more level
fours got a level fives down
here I'm scared they're going to make me
try to fight level fours here
soon
there's
I need a few level
fours I hope they
regenerate from 1987 to
[Applause]
[Music]
1994 yeah I want to see Bor I could
probably I don't know if I can deal
with
also the new movie I want to see
Bor that's how I feel like he he he's
important
man we got to find more level fours we
might have to jump to another
system I think I've like defeated did
all the fours in this
system B is race not a person
technically
so Borg is so it's not one person that
has the cube thing it's the whole race
that have the cube thing am I am I do I
I got this
correct so I got a
shipyard we're trying to make this
thing we need a shipyard level five now
oh
God okay so we need need a
bunch all right so we got a little bit
of that going for
us we need a level five
Academy what I want to do is go back to
where
though go back to where my ship
is all right we're looking for level
four what is
this there might not be no level fours
on this planet on this
galaxy okay there's level four right
here there's a couple fours we might be
good watch the Star Trek first content
movie if you like that then go back to
watch the rest okay Star Trek first
Contact first
[Applause]
[Music]
Contact all right we don't need level
five we need to find another level four
this
[Applause]
dude in order to level that up because I
want to level the shipyard
up okay hold
up enter your
station we need to level up this
Shipyard we still need a little bit
[Music]
more
stuff I have to let these cook a little
bit that's
fine uh let's go back to where my ship
is
um we need one more level four
dude so this dude should be
[Applause]
[Music]
it you defeated a hostile ship Commander
keep it
up
okay we can't build anything yet I like
some of the
like the US
Franklin some of these ships are crazy
looking what's the lot what's the
strongest thing right
now like look at this
thing this thing is
strong can you make one of the cubes can
you make
it you can make a
cube
you can make a
cube is way up there though it's way up
there a US Voyager that's
cool this game is
massive a hijack D3
class
let's see
here all right so we got
that got some speed UPS some level
UPS oh they want us to level fight level
fives now see now we're getting a little
bit too full of ourselves okay let's
return this to the ship
hold
up wait a minute we got a
recall and I got to go back to
the to our home
here enter your
station this thing's going to take a
couple seconds to get back that's fine
though
22 seconds still a little bit more that
we got to
do upgrade Shipyard to level two we are
attempting that we might be able to
actually what is
this oh lower debt
crew
this dude still
hasn't got enough to level up
that we need not we need we need three
more they're all almost
there all right we need to repair the
ship
y all
right I want to fight I want to fight
one of those cubes so bad I know I'm not
going to
win I'm so toxic I think I can
beat oh
manage yeah lower crew let's put badgy
there confirm that
upgrade level
up it says we only need one but we just
need to level up a little bit
more we got a little with
this oh we don't have enough of
that
we almost got
enough I'm
curious if we're going to be able to
fight the level
fives they're pretty strong hold up
Galaxy we should be able to have
enough
there we go ship level two Shipyard
level
two so we need a shipyard level
three that requires
[Music]
1,000 we do have an
instant all right how close are we
to upgrading
this thing I want to build this
thing before the ship we need level five
ship before I get off this stream I need
to build that I don't feel right unless
I build that I'm going be real with
you you don't see the Federation have
success against until later in the
series all right that's what's up all
right
let's we don't need that we really need
supplies
[Music]
okay I'm kind of C let's look at the
materials cuz obviously this game's got
its own monetary
[Music]
value I do enjoy
how a lot of this is pretty accessible
to what I'm
seeing I construct a dock B
we need
construction all right so let's look
here so you can't convert stuff into
materials and what do I need for
this we need a level five Shipyard
that's all we
[Music]
need we need a level six
operation oh get that we we need a uh we
need to buy to build the the
dog fleet commander now we good on that
I like
how like there's a lot of different
stuff that you can
[Music]
do all right so we're good there
we need to build a a fleet
[Music]
commander so I need 3,000 of those so we
need to do a little bit more to get
that all
right all right we're going back to
where we
was I'm kind of
curious I know I probably couldn't find
one of the bog ships like and you know
in my mind how bad could it be in my
mind I could take
him I feel like I could take him it
looks like there's a PVE ships now I'm
curious field training
[Music]
they give you a lot
of ways that you can earn stuff in game
this is one of those games where it's
like look you can wait but just playing
the game it's is like you know we're
going to reward you for playing the game
and I respect that I do I respect
that we need need operations in order to
get that we need
[Music]
this actually hold let's go back to the
dry dog hold
up we need this dry
dog oh we need
[Music]
3,000
all right
so so I've went through all my stuff
that's
[Music]
fine right so that's going to take a
little bit to build that's
fine let's go back to the level five
though
man
[Applause]
[Music]
I dad just hit a four or a five okay so
you right there off the bat pretty good
let's do another level five it didn't
take too much from
me I think we're
good I think we're good it didn't take
too much from
[Music]
me
[Applause]
the hold
go
[Music]
wanted to switch to my
account all right so we uh take on a
couple you know
what CU I I do got to go here soon
because we um we're going to be doing an
ILP stream actually playing GTA 5 I'm
sure that'll be fun you guys know how
you guys like making fun of me all right
so we can't go there can we go here no
we
can't oh what could only so much you you
could do
[Music]
let's got to upgrade stuff to get it
what's the highest strongest thing on
this
map hold up guys give me a
second
[Music]
no level six
okay we need to take out one more level
five I think we can do
[Music]
[Applause]
it come on come on
we did
it got a bunch of XP some uh some
Soldier rank
[Music]
UPS defeat a hostile Comm
what
[Music]
ooh all right we doing that I got it in
the stream here soon but we're doing
that we taking on that Captain hold up
you guys know how I I'm a little bit too
competitive when it comes to stuff like
that re recalling
that it's going to take him a little bit
to get back that's fine we doing that
guys we fighting that like I said the
link in the chats to the game
guys get on here and try some of
[Music]
this
okay
okay the game is
easier this game is easier than the
previous first First Command Fleet okay
hold on we
repairing cuz you guys know me I'm a f
away if I don't fight this
[Music]
thing ooh I'm hoping I could beat this
watch this Commander beat me I'm going
be so upset if he somehow beats
[Music]
me okay here we go okay we got the ship
back
attack 13 seconds oh here we go guys
here we go all right all right you think
we could do it you guys think we can do
it hostile
Captain I'm nervous I think we got
it right there you guys know how it is
you guys know I ain't going to lose that
oh they want me to delete a level six or
higher I think we could do
[Music]
that
interior
[Music]
okay we're almost there I'm going fight
a level six and then we're going to
start to close out of the
[Music]
game all right level six right here I
think we fought a level six oh God hold
up oh that's going to be a a close fight
I might lose
that it's going to be a close
[Applause]
[Music]
fight
ooh it's took took a lot of my dam it
took a lot of damage out of me that's
for
sure Shiva who's that who is
that all right hold up let's look at my
ship manage I think I got a
new yeah I'm a little
[Music]
damaged
all right
[Music]
guys woo that felt
nice is he back
yet
I wish I had a little bit more time I
want to see what that ship looks
like repair
fre I think I have some upgrades let me
look real
quick assign officers I think I got new
[Music]
officers
standard
recruitment okay
[Music]
yeah this
changes tiar
up take 16 minutes that's fine I got to
get off anyway all right
guys man I really enjoyed that that that
that two hours flew by it
flew hold up let
me oh wrong
[Music]
thing there we go man that that that
flew let me see someone said the
previous was like a star filled space
combat no actually really enjoyed this
type of
style you know it's something easy I can
like jump on and play a little bit but
like I said man right there click that
join it try it out yourself man you know
it's it's one of those time consuming
games where you just play as time goes
by you know it it's it's just a chill on
your couch you know let's see what's
going on in Starfield fleet commander
man it's interesting now I really want
to keep grinding this game and I want to
fight that Cube I want I want to have
that Cube we'll see man we'll see but I
appreciate for coming through like I
told you guys right there is the link
it's the link to our affiliate code
definitely uh I don't know if it's
technically called an affiliate code I
don't know but once again want to
thank Star Trek fleet commander for uh I
think it's Fleet command my bad guys I
want to thank uh Star Trek Fleet command
for the sponsorship opport o Unity it
was a pleasure working with you guys it
was a it was a fun time man this
actually showed me that you know I
actually want to play this uh appreciate
it though guys I appreciate it
appreciate it Cleo Walker you know
anyone in there wants to try the game
out I recommend trying it I do and I
thank you babe my babe said in there the
whole time with me definitely hit that
like button as you guys went out you
know we're gonna be playing GTA 5 here
pretty soon some Halo infinite maybe I
don't know we got to talk to King I
appreciate every guys coming through and
uh I'll talk to you guys later peace
actually let's see see if there's anyone
that we can raid because you know even
with the the little people we do have in
here I want to try to to to you know
bless someone with some
[Music]
viewership um s you guys over there a
Wandering Dutch I appreciate you guys
all coming through IOP will be back in
the next couple weeks we're out of here